إذا كانت أمريكا تغادر أفغانستان
بعد ما يقرب من عقدين من الدماء
والكنوز المفقودة ،
فما الذي يتركه العالم وراء
معقل طالبان الأفغاني العادي ، فموسى خاله هو المكان الذي
مات فيه العديد من الجنود الأمريكيين والبريطانيين
الآن ، فهذه لقطة لكيفية
إدارة طالبان لأفغانستان
كما يكسبون.  طلبنا السلطة لستة رجال
يعيشون هناك أيضًا أمام الكاميرا دون الكشف عن
هويتهم بأمان ،
ما هو الحال باختصار قاتمة بالنسبة
للنساء ، بعض الهواتف الذكية ، لكن بالنسبة لجميع
عدالة طالبان وضرائب طالبان ، هناك عواقب
إذا لم تدفعوا يضربونك أو
يسجنونك
على نطاق واسع من القرون الوسطى  بعد ذلك ، أخذ المجتمع في
الاعتبار كل المليارات التي تم إنفاقها
باستثناء مؤخرًا فقط مع الهاتف الذكي الغريب ، مما
سمح لنا
بهذه الطريقة التي التقطنا بها صورًا
لشوارع
طالبان تتجول في السوق نحن مشاة البحرية بمجرد قيامنا
بدوريات قبل 10 سنوات ،
كان الأمريكيون متمركزين هنا في موقع
يمكنك رؤيته على صور الأقمار الصناعية هذه
ليست بعيدة.  من المحل الفارغ حيث
للطالبان ملاعبهم المؤقتة
التي يسمونها غرفة الاستغناء
السريع الوحشي
تعتمد عقوبات العدالة على ما
يريده الطرف الآخر إذا سامح المدعي
قاتلًا ، فقد لا تصدر المحكمة حكمًا بالإعدام ،
ولكن إذا طالب الأقارب ،
على سبيل المثال ، قبل حوالي أربع سنوات ،
تم شنق ثلاثة لصوص حتى الموت من
عمود الكهرباء
على الطريق للخارج  من المدينة حتى
يرى الناس أنه تم القبض عليهم
عدة مرات بتهمة السرقة ، لكنهم لم
يمنعوا
هذه اللقطات من رحلة بالسيارة حول المدينة
متجهين إلى مخيمات اللاجئين على ضفاف
النهر حيث اعتدنا إطلاق النار علينا
، ومن الواضح أن
عدد قليل من النساء  يُسمح لهم بالخروج إلى الشوارع
، ولا يزالون لا يذهبون إلى المدرسة ،
ولا يجرؤ أحد على السؤال
عما قيل لنا ، لكن معظم الرجال الذين سألناهم
قالوا إن النساء إذا كان ذلك جيدًا ، فهذا ما
قصدوه
أنه لا يُسمح لهن بممارسة الأعمال التجارية
خارج منزلهن
عندما  يجب أن يرتدوا ملابسهم في الخارج
وفقًا لأحكام الشريعة الإسلامية ،
لذا فمن المهم بالنسبة لهم
الاعتناء بمنازلهم
أكثر من العمل في الخارج ، كما يمكن للمرأة أن تحصل
على عدالة قاسية
في هذا العالم المتخلف.  تمت
إدانتها بتهمة الزنا
وسجنت منذ خمس سنوات الآن
ولا أحد يعرف ماذا سيحدث لها
في النهاية ، وقتل الرجل الذي تم القبض عليه معها على
يد أصهاره
لأنه جلب العار على زواجه
[موسيقى]
القتال نادر الحدوث  هنا الآن ويجب على
الأمريكيين أن
يشاهدوا فقط من الطائرات أو الطائرات بدون طيار أعلاه
في الواقع قيل لنا إن طالبان
سمحت فقط ببعض الهواتف الذكية في موسى كارلا
لأن محادثات السلام تعني
أن الغارات الجوية الأمريكية هناك قد أبطأت من
سرعة الأمريكيين كانوا يستخدمون
الهواتف الذكية لتتبع
حكم مقاتلي طالبان  في هذه الشوارع يعني
أنهم يفرضون ضرائب على محاصيل الأفيون أو المتاجر
التي قيل لنا
أو نطلب الخبز أو الملابس
لمقاتليهم عند الحاجة ،
لكن البعض قال إن الخلافات بين
مجموعات طالبان تعني أن الناس يمكن أن يدفعوا أكثر من
مرة
تم اصطحاب العديد من الأشخاص إلى
غرفة طالبان  حبسوا لمدة ليلة أو ليلتين
أو تعرضوا للضرب هناك
مجموعة مختلفة من
طالبان ، سيكون من الأفضل أن يكون هناك مسؤول واحد في
السلطة يخضع للضريبة
ولكن كل  تحاول المجموعة جباية ضرائب
على جيوبهم ،
وهذه مشكلة واحدة للناس الآن ،
ثم تستمر الحياة كما فعلت
قبل إزاحة طالبان من السلطة
بعد 11 سبتمبر
مع خسارة الكثير من الأمريكيين
والأفغان في المعركة بين نيك بايتون
والش.  سي إن إن
كابول